let's jump to the story we gotta we got
a story from the post-millennial antifa
members sentenced to 60 months probation
for May 2021 Portland Riot that's
arsonby was charged with arson yeah he
was uh Jared Bailey Hoover pleaded
guilty to one count of arson in the
second degree one count of criminal
mischief in the first degree and one
count of Riot and he got 60 months
probation every single January 6th
defendant right they're not mocking him
up they're like all right we'll just
call us there's just a warning you just
set buildings on fire he was just
expressing himself exactly he's a
creative kid it's free speech it was
self-defense you know what he had to set
the building you guys know like that
famous graphic that goes around of all
like what antifa looks like right like
the and it's just like the ugliest of
them all it's funny because that night
that graphic I'm the one person that was
left out of that graphic because that
night I was arrested with them because I
was in Black Block recording on the
ground spent a whole night in jail with
them but then I never seen me on the
graphic oh wow yeah and I was like but
all the people that were on the graphic
I was sitting in jail with alongside all
night talking I was on the graphic
because they edited me to look less
handsome I was gonna say are you guys
just telling us you're handsome I don't
understand I mean hold on hold on here's
the inverse we have the story from the
Daily Mail New York City mother of three
who slammed into BLM protesters if they
terrorized her finally accepts plea deal
she will she would send us to five hours
of community service instead of six days
which was offered but she was facing
seven years so this is a video where
they surround her vehicle she's with her
29 year old daughter they're screaming
banging and then she hits the gas and
just boom and these people go flying
motor community service nobody got any
serious serious injuries but she hasn't
done it yet she has to do five hours and
then if she does she will be able to uh
that's it she's out so the issue here is
it's kind of good news the better news
would have been that she was not
convicted at all because she was
attacked and she was panicking trying to
hurt her kids but she said that she
acted dentally hit the gas in a panic
and that she didn't mean to hurt anybody
and that's why they said okay fine we'll
give you uh five hours community service
but this is good news because this woman
was originally facing seven years it was
a big deal we were like this is crazy
they surround your vehicle this was
several months after in Provo Utah they
shot a driver that's uh John Sullivan
same guy that was there on January 6 in
the room alongside me with Ashley
Babbitt that was his Group insurgents
USA in in Provo Utah yep he was actually
arrested during that same day uh during
that protest so it goes back far but
another thing that hasn't hit the news
yet that actually I think will be good
news regarding antifa kind of inverse to
the Portland one is last week in Texas
outside of one of these Fort Worth drag
shows
um you know antifa decided to go up to a
Catholic group and mace them while they
were preying on their rosaries and it
was all caught on security camera the
cops went and arrested him while he was
there and then in response the leader of
the group Christopher gullet leader of
John Brown Gun Club
um you know he went and he decided he
would assault a police officer while uh
armed with a firearm and then same with
one of their Medics decided to assault a
police officer when was this this was
last week and it didn't really get a lot
of attention in the news it got a little
bit you know Andy no put it out because
that's his thing
um and you know there I think they are
going to face felony charges I don't see
how you can assault a police officer in
the state of Texas while you're armed I
did not saying it was in Fort Worth
we'll see yeah well we'll see I mean
Fort Worth PD though it was crazy to see
that response because you know I've seen
them be violent in Dallas I've seen them
be violent all around Texas and to do
things that would warrant arrest but the
cops never do anything regarding the
drag shows and regarding antifa this was
the first time that I've actually seen a
police force actually do something and
use some Force do you feel like they're
becoming more confident I felt like for
a while people didn't know how to react
to antifa because they are they're
becoming more that's why they're
becoming violent I think is it's getting
close to election season things are
heating up I mean I'm on list I can't
even go into these shows anymore because
they specifically stand armed outside
these events because of my coverage now
so usually I have to send somebody or go
in a really good disguise or find one
that they're distracted here so I gotta
go do this other one in a different part
of town wow but they're becoming more
violent and that's how it always is is
as you get closer to the summer that's
when violence really occurs during the
summer it's just insane right so this
person this dude burns down a building
doesn't see any prison time thankfully
this woman didn't get in trouble for
defending herself and her children I
know she said she accidentally hit the
gas but when people surround your car
after someone was already shot who was
in their car after I mean look granted
it was a few decades ago but what was it
Rodney King during the Rodney King riots
that trucker was Bull pulled out of his
truck and being beaten just severely
beaten these kinds of things happen when
a mob surrounds your car that's
extremely dangerous and why should you
be forced to risk your children's Life
by sitting there while these people are
terrorizing it's absurd there was a
video out of Chicago of that where they
surrounded a guy's car and dragged him
out and started beating them and that
you're saying that's that's the thing
you're supposed to let that happen
because when somebody gets beaten or
killed by the mob it's not a news story
but when they defend themselves it's a
national tribe they're good kids man
they're just misunderstood okay just you
know I'm mostly peaceful beating that's
what I expect the story about the uh the
subway vigilante in New York
I think that was before my time yeah but
it was like crime was really bad in the
80s and then he had a gun yeah and he
shot some like dudes we said we're
robbing him and then they claimed they
weren't robbing him but everybody
cheered for him the guy was paralyzed
right I don't know that was well before
my time I mean that's the thing though
is I think as like you know places like
New York and in these high crime areas
is you're going to start especially
during 2024 and election season as
things heat up you're gonna see some
vigilantism yeah you're gonna see people
carrying out what the police are
supposed to be they're going to be the
ones you know handing the pain down to
antifa into these other radical groups
that are trying to quite literally kill
these people and it's just gonna get
worse and worse because when the cops
aren't going to do their job in the DA's
they're not going to prosecute who else
has to do it yeah I mean you're going to
get more Kyle Rittenhouse situations as
well and looking at this contrast 60
months probation I mean being serious
against the felonies the people who
entered the capital have been charged
with right like there is an obvious bias
so you can't even trust that if someone
is arrested for you know gently burning
down your business that they are
actually going to serve an adequate
punishment I think that would be only
encourage our low trust Society to start
to tear apart oh well also I think I'm
sorry I don't know why it it's the case
that arson just isn't a big deal to
people anymore burning down a building
to go to jail for less than a decade for
something like that is absurd you know
how many people you can kill just the
completely Reckless abandon the lack of
consideration for human life you're a
danger to society if you do something
like that it's not even just a question
of whether you need to be punished it's
whether you should be allowed outside
and the answer is no you shouldn't be
that person should be locked up for
decades well I bet you weren't a
building down right in a city where it
could have spread to any number exactly
it's out of control I also think if we
looked up any other arson you would find
that they get much more time it's
because of the affiliation with the the
summer of peace or whatever we call it
uh and antifa that this person is
getting special treatment like they are
rewarding someone who intentionally
tried to
basically hurt other people I mean
exactly well there's there's a point to
be made here about what's called moral
luck so if this person had set this
building on fire and there had been 10
people inside who died
they wouldn't be a different kind of
person than this individual was their
moral character would be identical they
just happened to get lucky in the sense
or maybe unlucky from their perspective
that no one was in there for them to be
able to kill with their arson but what
they did is absolutely not different at
all they just happened to have the
fortunate legal outcome for themselves
that nobody died I mean I remember in
2020 uh one of the first times I was on
the ground in Portland it was night a
hundred
um an antifa member decided they wanted
to throw a Molotov cocktail it was
insane within the first five minutes of
them marching and they threw it at the
police they missed hit their own guy and
lit him on fire and that's where like
the pants on fire clip came from oh yeah
yeah and you know when way viral trump
retweeted it and then all of a sudden no
charges he hit his own guy but he was
trying to kill police officers the
police officers literally had to walk
over and put him out but nobody else was
doing it they were trying to hit him
with a duct tape Shield it's like yeah
that's great that's going to put them
out but there's no repercussions of that
like he tried to kill multiple police
officers and I never saw any charges
from that they never knew who he was
exactly so what's happened right now is
the state is not merely failing to
uphold civility it is act actively
anti-civil when somebody tries to
protect themselves or their property or
someone else they end up getting locked
up but when somebody goes out and they
destroy things they either don't get
locked up or they get a slap on the
wrist because that's what you're
supposed to do you're supposed to go out
and Destroy things that's the current
Paradigm right and I I can't imagine you
know with stories out of Portland right
like Portland is a liberal City at some
point don't the residents there start
saying like this is not working for us I
mean businesses have already basically
completely moved out of Portland I know
some business owners there that they
have lost literally their livelihoods
because of these riots in 2020 and they
don't know what to do nobody wants to
open new businesses there you still go
to Portland there's hardly anywhere to
eat anymore everything is still shut
down basically completely like that is
my least favorite place to go one
because the energy in the air you can
feel that there's something inherently
wrong and demonic going on there but two
you can't get any food and if you do
it's like 90 bucks for something super
small and it's only take out
non-contactless I thought insurance
would pay for it crazy that's what we're
told right because you guys know that
you know that insurance because
Insurance exists you can destroy
anything you want for any reason and no
one's harmed in actuality the insurance
have caps exactly so people will go into
debt just cleaning up the wreckage of
their business before they even start
rebuilding it what happened in Minnesota
was that they nobody could get paid out
so the buildings just were destroyed I
mean you've seen the before and after
pictures it's apocalyptic this is the
thing it's not just that the buildings
are destroyed and gone forever the
business owner has to pay to clean the
rubble up right so not only is their
business destroyed now whatever savings
they had if they had any are going to be
wiped out trying to clean the property
trying to get all the rubble off of it
because you're not allowed to just leave
a half burnt building standard there's
there's
evil
in fact infested in in our government
like you mentioned the cops Shake You
Down at the border like those are evil
people it's anti civility yeah they
actively work against Civil Society
they're not just failing to do their
Duty they're working in the opposite
direction
they want to destroy it well it's the
same thing with the the cops that don't
want to enforce you know these uh these
drag shows they don't want to go in and
arrest anybody because oh it's going to
look bad on social media or we might get
fired from our jobs it's like that is
literally your job there are laws being
broken
when there's children there yeah because
what the left keeps trying to say is the
right is Banning drag shows and then
they come out like heaven bacon saying
hey drag's fine it's like nobody cares
about drag they care about them having
burlesque shows for children that's not
appropriate
exactly I mean it's crazy that we even
have to say that like I just came out
with that piece that you guys published
thank you Tim I appreciate it um and
Chris if you're watching Chris Bertman
you're awesome thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time